uh earlier i got news okay
from the bodybuilding community okay and
we're talking about this a little bit
right now and i want to kind of come to
you because
uh oh
and you know caroline's like you know i
think it's a good idea to come out and
come talk to phil i was on a zoom with
the board and all this other stuff so i
stepped out and fell and i we have a
conversation together
and a george peterson 37 years old who
was competing for i believe the 212 uh
mr olympia class yeah uh today uh news
comes out he's supposed to compete this
weekend he's in orlando he posted a
story just 12 hours ago
and he posted uh something on instagram
just a day ago that he's eating the meal
in his room they find him dead
and a lot of different stories came back
and this is from evolution of
bodybuilding the story i was reading
about that was shared with me but uh you
know
there's a lot of things that's going on
right now phil you're in this world i'm
not in this world if you don't mind
sharing yeah that's georgia peterson at
37 years old
just a beautiful physique and a really
really good man in my
my heart goes out to him
his family his sister his mother
it's tough that like when i found out
you know i was very upset
i'm still upset
um
this one hurts pretty hard because
you know when you go on tour together
and you know you travel the world you do
the expos you do all those things you
get to know each other a little bit
you know different than just uh hitting
each other up on social media
you get to see that that smile
was real
always smiling when he was talking and
stuff and i mean this this is i mean
look at this physique
just incredible it is beautiful
and he worked he worked so hard and we
don't know the cause of it so i'm not
going to speculate
i just want to celebrate his life and
and as a human being i mean he was a
really good person and you know going
into this weekend it's it's
you know i'm not going to be attending
you know i just i just want everyone
that is attending
to celebrate george
you know
um the bodybuilding community is
actually really strong and they're very
resilient when things like this happen
unfortunately they do happen
um and we've had
a lot of death
within our industry over the past 18
months
is it more than usual phil i would say
so you know there was a couple guys you
know a couple suicides you know and
obviously during covenant and stuff like
that yeah people weren't able to go to
the gym and that was like their
you know their thing escape their escape
exactly um
what what bothered me the most and that
gerard was able to uh you know allow me
to have some time to chat about it was
he was by himself
and that's what i i'm i'm having a hard
time with because you know during the
week of the olympia guys i mean we are
uh
you know very very lean
and
you know we we do things you know to try
to get rid of water and stuff like that
and you know we do a lot you know we're
just exhausted guys we're exhausted and
and the biggest thing that i always
tried to maintain was a you know a core
nucleus of friends and people you know
my trainer honey rambot is actually you
know the coach of hottie chopin and a
few other guys and that are getting
ready for the show
hani um was always with me
no matter what he would watch me
he would watch me he watched me pose he
just didn't leave my side just in case
if something went wrong like in 2009 not
just trying to make it about myself i
had food poisoning he was there that
when the emt showed up he was there he
didn't leave
so
you know i know i don't want to call out
his trainer or anything like that i just
to be honest as a to be selfish i want
to know what happened
you know i personally i just want to
know what happened and i hope that the
truth comes out
is is protocol for somebody to always be
with the person that's competing like
especially at this level in his
situation
what people don't recognize and i didn't
preface this is that
you know george used to compete in
classic and then he moved up to 212 and
in 212 uh just so everybody knows this
212 is 212 pounds
so he
you know you're normally starting off
let's just say you start off at 245
pounds you're dieting down and you know
you compete
you know and this is like a heavyweight
boxer or boxer you know they they got to
weigh in and stuff you guys
what i was told is that you know he was
you know basically he was already at the
top of his weight division
and it was already going to be difficult
but you know i heard that he was a
little bit too big
and when i say too big like you know the
guy was he he maybe could have competed
in open you know
because maybe his body just wanted to be
bigger i guess you know and when i say
bigger it's not like a 225 230 yeah or
yeah yeah well maybe maybe he would be
you know better at that but he but the
fact is is that when you when you try to
suck down just like a like in wrestling
or something like that in high school
whatever you know you're trying to make
weight
and um
like without heavily speculating i just
feel like you know when you're trying to
make weight it becomes very difficult
you know you could be wearing a sauna
suit you could be doing all these other
things and you're already exhausted so
you know when the news comes out you
know when the you know hopefully we
actually get the truth you know i think
it's when i say the truth i want to know
because it's imperative that we
understand as athletes because we are
elite like we're at the top
but i don't know how to address like
what happened without knowing what
happened just out of curiosity let me
speculate let me speculate out of
curiosity
is in back in the days
i remember diuretics was a big deal i
remember like one time something
happened to paul dalet you remember the
whole thing when he locked up and they
were talking about you know all this
stuff and sean ray had an incident we
even talked about it on the program i
think where he won the classic and then
it was given away i don't know what
happened something happened with yeah
they were checking for diuretic usage
and i believe that he um you know tested
positive so what is a diuretic
you know basically it's heart blood
heart
blood pressure meds
you know it helps you know get rid of
water
essentially it sucks it sucks everything
out of your body so you've already got
so you've already got like you know no
fat left you hope that you do okay and
then if you have like a little bit of
film of water and stuff i mean just to
get you know everything dried out drying
your body yes
and you're you know you cut you can to
be quite honest you can push it
and um you know
i mean look like this is f1 you know
this isn't you know like you guys can
understand what i'm saying of course
yeah but but was it was it illegal that
became a leak was it something that was
frowned upon that mr olympia started
saying it's okay if you take it now like
they don't test for it anymore i don't
know you know there's random you know
there's rent it's random got it so you
know he wasn't this is not to say that
he was no at all exactly but i you know
i'm just going to lean on the fact that
you know
he was by himself and i and i just wish
that he wasn't and
you know i can you know and i'm not
going to point blame the trainer i'm
just saying like i just
i just know like from my experience i
always had someone with me whether it be
my trainer or my girl you know someone
because
i just feel like it's very important to
monitor
anything like just and just to keep your
mind you know like because when i get
ready for the olympia
i'm so dehydrated for like three days
that my mind like i can't i can't
process thoughts
so i just need someone to kind of like
keep my mind off what would your message
be if you could convey anything to the
participants this weekend to
for especially for i'm going to speak to
the 212 guys
you're going to go up there and you're
going to give it everything you got but
you're going to remind yourself that
george is not there and you're going to
pose for him
and in the event that um
you guys can come together
and create some type of message
to
to support one another um you do it and
um
moving forward we just have to you know
we're going to always compete at a very
high level but we got to remind
ourselves that um we're not promised
anything
and um just celebrate his life because
we all got the pictures and stuff you
know i don't know what to post
yeah i don't know what to say but all i
know is that like you know he's he's
he's passed on
and i'm and i'm sad
and um you know my heart goes out to his
family
you know he has a ton of friends
in our industry
he was he was just the nicest guy